so it's really important that this  country a country of immigrants uh  continues uh to welcome folks um and  abide by its humanitarian uh you know  values it's really important that we  welcome folks just not here  it's just really awful what they're  doing in texas sending these immigrants  to new york if you if you just listen to  that clip you don't see what's on the  wall directly behind him uh to his left  right behind him  on the right of the screen you see a  sign that says no raids  no wall  new york is for all  and then on the left of the screen you  see no hate no fear immigrants are  welcome here and both signs say new york  city new york city right underneath  except for these immigrants they got to  stay in texas it's because it's so  important to welcome them in texas  and not in new york is for all except  for the immigrants that are being bused  from texas we don't please keep them in  texas